all right something that came up during
the program in the airing of grievances
we didn't have much time to talk about
it though the stephen jones comments
from wednesday about agents and he
didn't single any agents out but the
cowboys co in talking generally about
agents said i have a lot of respect for
most agents i really do i think they're
trying to do their job for these players
but i do think sometimes they don't have
the end game that maybe the players
should and we do i think sometimes our
players have to realize that
representatives don't always have what's
in the best interest getting the very
most they can for the players may not be
in the interest of their long-term
future if they want to and i'm totally
con convinced all our players do want to
win championships and keep these young
players right now i don't think the
representatives and they're all good
ones feel like that's their problem look
i i understand that agents are primarily
focused on maximizing the recovery for
the player because that maximizes the
recovery for themselves but
do not tell me
that the team
has the player's long-term best interest
at heart they do not by definition they
do not the team worries about what the
team what did jerry jones say tuesday
the team takes precedence not the player
the team so the player doesn't care
about the long-term best interest of the
player think about this chris right now
the cowboys have 90 guys on the roster
right 37 of them are going to be said
see you later we love you thanks for
everything you did now get the hell out
of here they're not laying the
foundation for these guys long-term
futures they want what's best for the
team what's best for the team is getting
these guys to take less and if you can
undermine their relationship with their
agents to get them to take less you're
acting in the best interest of the team
that's what this is all coming from guys
so don't fall for it they are trying to
help themselves they're not trying to
help you they help themselves by
convincing you that your agents aren't
helping you i don't think the jones
family became the jones family by the
approach of uh we won't try to get the
most we can get i don't think so i just
have a feeling oil tycoons what they do
with the cowboys it always seems like
they're trying to get the most they can
get out of everything so i don't like
that hypocritical stance let alone
there's no such thing as long-term
future in the nfl and it doesn't exist
at the running back position so you know
again you can cry me a river with all
that crap talk that's just not true i
just i can't stand you know i'm on the
player's side and i'm especially an
ezekiel elliott side with this one and
oh yeah long-term future until what he
comes out there and sacrifices his body
again and then tears an acl and an mcl
and then there is no long-term future
it's now the future is now and that's
what ezekiel is trying to do and uh i'm
i'm rooting for ezekiel elliott as you
know and i think you are too hey i said
yesterday if jerry jones was the agent
of any of the three guys on offense are
trying to pay he would be on top of a
table screaming that these guys are
worth every penny and these are the guys
who are the ones who put on the uniform
cross the white line and put their
bodies at risk on every given day and
you know as well as anyone you can't i
mean hey yeah you can break your leg you
also could die on the field as you
almost did and that's not anything to
joke about and i'm not joking about it
the point is this the players are the
ones taking the risks with their futures
they're taking the risks with their
lives they're the ones who have the
skills and abilities and the idea that
they should do anything other than try
to get the most they can for those
skills and abilities is wrong and i
understand why the cowboys are trying to
do it because they've got this great
team now they're trying to hold together
so they can win championships and build
their own legacy and and
yeah it's got me pissed off i guess and
i love and i love what the joneses do
for football but let's not get the roles
twisted right and whether it's a guy
who's representing himself whether it's
a guy who hires a lawyer to help him out
on an hourly rate whether it's an agent
who takes a percentage
you are in control of the player's
interest and the team never is and don't
let anyone ever tell you that the team
is acting in the best interest of the
players they are always and only acting
in the best interest of themselves and
that's the way it's supposed to be yep
uh a hundred percent and and you know
too i know
i'm not on the jones family side with
this conversation but you you did say
that they've done a lot of great things
from the sport and i do respect that but
you know again this is just uh i don't
know bargaining talk whatever it is
they're trying to lower the price
they're trying to
twice this week in my opinion yes yeah
it crosses a line by by questioning or
by trying to force
the players to question
whether the people hired to look out for
their best interests are really looking
out for their best interests and and
look there are some conflicting
motivations that come into play agents
have said i don't get three percent of
the super bowl ring i don't care if my
guy wins a championship but
the team is i mean this is a hansel and
gretel thing they are luring you into
the house with candy folks that's what
they're trying to do
you're right anyway yeah all right
i own no more
and again the joneses are great for
football and they've done fabulous
things in 30 years of ownership of the
cowboys and they have advanced the sport
but they are never acting in the best
interest of the players they're acting
in the best interest of themselves of
the league of their business of the
cowboys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports